- Oh, I just noticed,
he's urinating.
Okay.
This changes a lot of things.
(bell rings)
(rolling sound)
(upbeat music)
I am a tutor.
And then I also do modeling,
and content creation on the site.
I love the whole idea of tattoos.
I think it is just such an amazing thing
to be able to decorate yourself
with art that you like.
- [Narrator] What's Like
a tattoo red flag to you?
What's something where like
if you see it on somebody,
you're like,
(Ali laughing)
"Oh, no. Not my type"
- Maybe like a Bible quote,
or just some kind of life quote.
I also not the biggest fan
of like the rose and the dagger.
I hope no one is offended.
(Ali laugh)
(bell rings)
(funky upbeat music)
Oh, okay.
I like that it's not a skull,
but it's actually like a rib cage.
(flag ticking)
(record scratching)
The rose and the dagger.
I offended you earlier.
I am sorry about that,
but you have a cool snail here
and there's a clock on that.
There's a lot of time pieces here,
which is pretty dope.
I like how these look like
they could be like
Friday the 13th tattoos.
I love those.
(electric guitar strumming)
(Ali laughing)
These are pretty cool.
I think they're different.
All of them are pretty different.
Especially with the
moons that we have there.
8.1.
(bell rings)
(light upbeat music)
I like how slow these all are.
(Ali laughs)
Right away, I think this
is beautiful line work,
really crisp lines.
This little train going on.
(Ali laughs)
I'm not quite sure,
but I like it.
I think they also mesh
really well together.
I guess important thing is to
kind of have it incorporated.
This is beautiful.
An 8.6.
(bell rings)
(soft upbeat music)
Yes.
A fellow sleeve.
I do see,
what does this say here?
Forever grateful.
Good to know.
Yeah, a bird,
which I also have a bird.
I do like birds.
Is there anything on
the inside of your arm?
Oh,
we have a rose.
This is a granny tattoo in remembrance.
I'm assuming.
Very nice.
Of course, it's not my style,
but it's still a good tattoo.
A 7.3.
(Ali giggles)
That one is actually pretty nice.
I do like this one.
I'm a big fan of snake tattoos.
I have one on my forearm as well.
I also have a skull.
So this is actually very nice tattoo.
7.9.
(bell rings)
(soft ambient music)
I think this is a cherub,
which I also have.
(Ali laughs)
He doesn't have wings though.
He's just kind of like a naked baby,
which I can respect.
(flag ticking)
Oh, I just noticed,
he's urinating.
Okay.
This changes a lot of things.
It's still not a bad tattoo.
It's even bolder choice.
I will give it a 6.9.
(bell rings)
(wind swooshing)
I will have to eliminate
number five.
I'm so sorry.
(Ali laughs)
I think I was just a little bit shook.
It's a great tattoo.
- Why don't you like?
Come on.
It's a little
- It's very fun.
- piss baby.
(Ali laughs)
Come on.
It's adorable.
- Yeah, no, it is adorable.
Yes.
I love your face tattoo as well.
- Oh, thank you.
I appreciate it.
- Yes, yes.
- I definitely understand
it's not for everybody, so.
Yes.
- But keep rocking it.
(Nico laughs)
- Thanks.
(Ali laughs)
(bell rings)
- Oh, okay.
Do you have any meaning for this tree
or is it just a nice tree you like?
- [Alec] When I was a kid
I lost my like grandfather
at a really young age.
- I'm so sorry to hear.
- [Alec] So death kind of affected me
in a pretty great way.
My mom sort of to make me feel better,
kind of reassured me that you know,
there's life after afterwards.
And she said in heaven,
you know we'll always
meet by the biggest tree.
- That's a beautiful story.
Thank you for sharing.
Right away.
Nice nail color.
(magical sound)
Is this a cone, yes?
- [Zachery] Yeah.
- [Ali] Related to a tree.
Okay.
Does this have any meaning for you?
- [Zachery] I used to
play with pine cones a lot
with my little sister
and she's like the most important
person in the world to me.
- Braky.
- [Zachery] I had a big
part in raising her.
So I wanted to get a tattoo
to commemorate that a little bit.
- I'm curious to see if we have any color.
Yes, the sleeve.
Oh, there's more.
Oh, wow.
Okay.
I like the clouds.
Is this a very meaningful sleeve to you?
- [David] Yes.
- I'm assuming.
- [David] Yeah, definitely.
- Yeah, yeah.
Do you have anything like
further up on your shoulder?
- It was all the way up
- Can I see?
- to my like trap area.
- Oh, wow.
That does go all the way up.
I really do like how it's
all meshing well together.
It's all very similar themes.
- [David] They all kind of relate.
They go together just a long story short,
when I was 19,
I got in a car accident
and broke my back
and I just feel like,
God gave me a second chance at life, so.
- Oh, my.
- [David] You know,
that's basically where
all go comes together.
Forever grateful.
The Roman numerals went on the
day I got in a car accident
- I'm also glad to hear you're okay.
There's so many
- Yeah, thank you.
accidents that are going on.
Oh.
(Ali laughs)
(Roy laughs)
(flag ticking)
I don't see any tattoos.
- Yeah. I don't have tattoos on my leg,
but I was like,
I don't know,
it's going to show like style I guess.
- Oh, Okay.
(Ali laughs)
Okay.
Yes.
Converse fans.
- [Roy] Oh, yeah.
- Yeah.
(Ali laughs)
(Roy laughs)
(bell rings)
Again, these are all great tattoos.
I hope you don't take my
eliminations personally.
I will have to eliminate
contestant number three.
(bell rings)
(tensed music)
(upbeat music)
- You broke my heart.
- I'm so sorry.
I'm glad
- Hi, nice to meet you.
you survive though.
- Please to meet you.
- Hi, nice to meet you.
- Where are your tattoos at?
Let's see what you got.
- Oh gosh.
- I just want to take a peek.
What you got?
- I have some ears.
- Oh, nice.
Not much I can show with my arms,
but they're kind of just speckled.
- Love them, love them.
- Thank you. Thank you.
- Appreciate you.
(Ali laugh)
(bell rings)
(upbeat music)
- I see two of you are matching shoes.
Very nice.
I'm liking contestant number two's,
I like your top.
I like how you're leaving the tattoos.
So I remember.
Very nice.
- Thank you.
I see you have like a
little lightning bolt.
- Nice.
- That's David Bowie.
- Of course.
What do you guys do for work?
- [Alec] I'm a production assistant.
- [Zachery] I'm an audio engineer,
though I normally do
like live bands and stuff
- Oh my gosh.
- [Zachary] And I also
build apps sometimes.
- [Ali] Very nice.
What?
Video?
- [Roy] I'm part-time actor,
but I also work in clinical research.
- I love that.
I love two sides of the same coin.
That's very cool.
(Roy laughs)
- [Alec] So what do you do for a living?
- I am a tutor.
- [Alec] Oh.
So I currently teach math
for like younger elementary students.
So like around second to fifth grade.
And then I also do modeling
and content creation on the site.
- [Zachery] What are your passions?
- [Ali] Big fan of fashion and makeup.
Anything kind of having to do with beauty.
I also like playing games.
I'm planning on streaming soon.
Possibly.
How old are each of you?
- [Alec] 25.
- [Zachery] I'm 23.
- [Roy] 28.
- 20.
- No, no, no, nothing wrong with that.
That's great.
- [Roy] Yes.
- You're in your twenties.
- [Roy] Yeah.
(Ali laughs)
(Roy laughs)
(bell rings)
- Unfortunately, it will
be contestant number three.
Only because I am older than you.
(Ali laughs)
- Oh, no way.
- Which is, you know, not bad,
- How old are you?
- just personally.
23.
- Oh, I'm 28.
- Oh, 28.
- Oh, I'm sorry.
I heard 20.
- It's okay.
That's okay.
- Oh, I'm so sorry.
(Ali laughing)
I'm sorry.
- No, it's cool.
Yeah.
- Cool.
I like the style.
Thank you.
- Totally dig it.
- Yes.
- Very goth.
- The blacks.
- Hit me up.
Yeah.
- No hard feelings.
- Great. Right, right.
Next contestant,
I will have to eliminate
contestant number one.
Again, I'm so sorry.
I'm just a stranger.
Please don't take this to heart.
- No problem.
(Ali laugh)
- Nice to meet you.
I'm Ali.
- I nice to meet you,
I'm Alec.
- Oh, Alec.
Okay. We share something.
(Ali and Alec laugh)
(bell rings)
(romantic ambient music)
- Hi.
- Nice to meet you.
- I love your outfit.
- Oh, I thank you.
I love yours as well,
but you know this.
- Ali, right?
- Yes, Ali.
- Cool, cool, cool.
- I also love your dangly earrings.
- Thank you.
- You're such a fashionista.
- Can you roll up your sleeve?
I want to see your.
- Oh yes, yes. yes.
This is my,
- We both have snakes.
- Snakes.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Flowers, right?
I have like a skull,
random birds around here.
You have also a very nice eye color.
- Oh really?
- Yeah, right away.
- Thank you
Mine are fake,
but you know, it's okay.
- Cool.
- How do you feel about the
choice you made today, Ali?
- I don't regret anything.
(Ali and Zachery laugh)
I mean anything in general
- Will we be exchanging numbers,
making any plans?
- We can exchange information.
- Okay.
There we go.
Now we know.
- Play some Valorant.
Oh yes.
Oh, Val duo?
- Yeah, sure.
- Okay, here we go.
(Ali laugh)
Sounds good.
- [Narrator] How you guys feel?
Do you make any direct plans?
- Yes, yeah.
- Anyone that can't
- They are all so nice.
- handle this piss baby,
can't handle me, so.
You know, that's how it is.
- [Ali] Yes.
We come together.
- It it's a great piss baby.
- [Narrator] Well, thank you guys so much.
- Yes. Thank you for having us.
- [Narrator] You did it,
you survived.
- Yehey.
- [Narrator] And you two have each other.
(everyone laughing)
Awesome.